welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in stranger things season four has
been announced with a super cryptic
teaser that doesn't even tell us so much
as a release date but another less
literal ways it tells us there's so much
more like I'll take a tree clock over an
explicit plot summary any day so I'm
gonna break down the tree clock and this
whole teaser for all of its imagery and
miscible visual clues and the various
hints we've received about the fourth
season of stranger things from the final
episode of season 3 and the series
creative team spoiler warning the gays
dating my theories are predictions in
the being right let's get started okay
so the teaser begins with just a simple
title card of stranger things for with
the series title music but then it
flickers out switching to negative
colors and then BAM the titles now in
the upside down and it's filled with
clues
[Music]
okay so a lot of stuff to point out here
to the right of the title is a welcome
to Huck in sign the one that can be seen
on the town border and the reverse of
the one that Joyce lwill and Jonathan
passed as they left Hawkins in the
season three finale the words we're not
in Hawkins anymore appear on the screen
which you could just read literally as a
lot of them have left the town maybe to
somewhere like Chicago but I think the
contradiction here suggests that this is
the upside down version of Hawkins the
wording is obviously a nod to the Wizard
of Oz repeating we're not in Kansas
anymore and plenty of thematic parallels
between these two properties the
departure from a youths domestic world
to a surreal fantasy world with mirrored
elements you can see hoppers cabin in
the background the left the front porch
light mysteriously flickers out and on
the ground in the foreground is a
discarded newspaper just a bit too tough
to make it out and then of course on the
left is a clock embedded in a tree trunk
there appears to be a smear of blood on
the clocks face and it ticks away in a
short clip right as it hit midnight it
chimes so what can we learn from all
this
well those chimes are the first four
notes in the common eighth note melody
in many old timey clocks notably the
Westminster chimes of Big Ben in London
which is believed to be a variation of
the fifth and sixth bars of I know that
my Redeemer liveth from Handel's Messiah
and we could read into that to interpret
a hint that hopper the seemingly dead
Redeemer of the season three finale
actually live vith but even if you don't
buy into that clock chime history
connection there is definitely grounds
for hopper still being alive season
three ended with a post-credits scene of
a Russian based where a prisoner is
thrown in a cage with a demagogue on and
in that base there was another cell that
contained according to subtitles the
American and many believe that that
American is hopper who could have jumped
into the rift into the upside down right
before the explosion that seemingly
killed him perhaps the upside down
dimension overlaps spatially with our
dimension to allow another access point
in Russia through which hopper could
have traveled to end up in Russian
custody hoppers final words to 11 and
his written speech could have also been
a clue the shaky poor
dad keep the door open
three inches this case the door could
refer to the rift to the upside down in
the months since season three has
dropped hopper actor david harbor has
been up to some curious social media
behavior actually let's break down
hoppers twitter happen in a new okay
first notice how harbors profile banner
image is art of hopper literally upside
down suggesting the character could be
in a place that's like this also at one
point followers noticed harbor changing
his avatar every day to a new number
creating the string of numbers six one
eight six two five eight three one three
which in season three was the exact
phone number of Marie Baumann the frames
conspiracy theories that they brought
Alexi to and if you call that number the
show set up a voice recording of Baumann
saying this I'm guessing by harbors
tweets that Marie's something is related
to hopper and Marie as a Russian speaker
with Soviet contacts might have come
across something in his research about
an American in a Russian prison but it's
interesting to me how this teaser
focuses so much on time as a motif
notice the clock takes up to midnight
before it cuts to black it could be a
nod to the Doomsday Clock maintained by
scientists throughout the Cold War as a
way to convey how close the world was to
nuclear annihilation
which they set as midnight season one of
stranger things took place in winter
1983 season two in fall 1984 season
three and summer 1985 so that might
suggest that season four could take
place in 1986 at a time of year that
they haven't done yet spring and if you
know your history April 1986 was a time
that the world was arguably closer than
ever to nuclear disaster the incident at
Chernobyl so does this mean stranger
things war will be set in the historical
backdrop of the Chernobyl tragedy
well now that Craig Mason's emmy-winning
HBO miniseries showed us all how
horrific those events were a goonie
style adventure with Pripyat
firefighters getting buried in concrete
might come off as a bit tone-deaf so
did I think this clock might be pointing
in a slightly different direction though
with similar elements time travel I know
I know after avengers endgame pitching
time travel as a nerdy theory it's just
a bit done but time-travel is also one
of the big sci-fi tropes that stranger
things hasn't explored yet despite
making some big references to it
season 3 staged a major sequence to the
backdrop of a screening of Back to the
Future hoppers letter also used some
choice words to turn back the clock and
note that in that post-credit scene the
demagogue in' is alive but no date or
years provided could be a nude immigrant
or a resurrected somehow after its death
or it could be taking place before all
the events of seasons 1 through 3 it's
the physics of the interdimensional
upside down allow for the bending of the
laws of space perhaps it also allows
flexibility on the axis of time what if
hoppers journey into the upside down
actually took him back in time to Soviet
Russia like the late 70s a period in
which we learned the Dimmick organ was
their creation that they released into
this dimension divorced from space and
time to appear years later in the United
States in 1983 and if you really want to
get tinfoil with this maybe hopper is
the Dimmick organ like after his flesh
was transformed also in earlier time
also in Russia like we don't see this
American in the post-credits scene we
only see the demagogue in if you think
about the demagogue in is a weirdly
rogue being in the upside down it's this
realm that's otherwise only populated by
the mind flayer like I just think
there's a lot more to the demagoguery
that we don't know yet but if time
travel is a possibility in season 4 the
upside down could be revealed to be not
another dimension but another time for
example Hawkins after a nuclear or
biological weapons disaster that left it
a lifeless void with raining radioactive
ash and mutant plant growth and that
machine that opens the rift is not a
portal across dimensions but forward and
potentially backward in time if so the
stranger things kids could use these
mechanics of time-travel to rewrite
history save hopper save barb say Bob
save Billy save Alexi save everyone
they've lost saved the whole damn world
and reset 1980s history the way we know
it
in our reality without insane
international conspiracies and sci-fi
crap going down in small-town Indiana
now hopefully we'll see a release date
of sometime late 2020 but until then or
whenever this comes out what 80s movie
plot device do you think could inspire
stranger things for comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA vas and
subscribe to new rock stars or
breakdowns of everything you love thank
you for joining me and if copper equals
time-traveling Russian demagogue in ends
up being rights that's quite a character
arc
[Music]